we're now to those escalating tensions
on the european union's eastern border
eu foreign ministers today agreed to
expand sanctions against belarus in
retaliation for what they called the
engineering of a migration crisis at
europe's doorstep the new measures will
target officials travel agents and
airlines which help to bring migrants to
belarus most of those migrants coming
from middle eastern countries thousands
of men women and children are stranded
in freezing conditions on the frontier
with poland
warsaw has declared an exclusion zone
along the border and is not allowing aid
workers or journalists
access
at least nine people are known to have
died trying to cross the border in
recent weeks
crowds of people gathered on the belarus
side of the border hoping to cross into
poland just some of more than an
estimated 4 000 camping out in freezing
forests in the hope of making a new life
in the european union
but the eu doesn't want to let them in
it accuses belarus of manufacturing the
crisis as retribution for earlier
sanctions the bloc imposed on minsk
and
of giving refugees false hopes of
crossing the border
what we're experiencing from minsk
this inhumane
system of using refugees as tools to
exert pressure on the european union
has not changed
but got worse over the last days
after talks on monday the eu foreign
ministers agreed on steps to tackle the
situation we are looking at all possible
solutions to start the regime the
lukashenko regime
from targeting us
and from targeting its own population
and we agreed
to expand the scope
of the sanctions regime on belarus
in what seemed to be an attempt to ward
off those sanctions belarus said it now
wanted to return migrants home
but that they did not want to go
[Music]
these people i must say are very
stubborn no one wants to return and
understandably so they have nowhere to
go back to they have no place to live
there they know there's nothing to feed
their children with
moreover some are simply afraid for
their lives
the polish interior ministry has
announced that in december it will start
building a wall along about half the
border to keep refugees and migrants out
but some polish locals are aware of the
desperate situation of the people who
have somehow made it across the border
they signal an offer of emergency help
with a green light in the darkness
and a chance at survival
well to discuss this situation i'm
joined now by the german lawmaker metin
hock verdi he's a social democrat member
of the german parliament he is a
spokesman on eu affairs mr hargreaty
it's good to have you back on the
program
when we have heard from these migrants
at the border area where they've been
asked where they want to go almost all
of them say in unison it's not poland
they all want to go to germany
does that give germany or impose upon
germany a special responsibility for
these migrants or what's the thinking
among lawmakers such as yourself
of course we have a special
responsibility not only because of the
fact
uh which you just stated that most of
them
are stating that they want to go to
germany but also of course because of
the size of germany or responsibility
for every european issue within the
european union but then of course
because we are in the middle of europe
and
are not one of the border states outside
the europe that have a border outside
the european union that makes us of
course special
reliable
and we've seen germany and and poland
standing
in solidarity on this issue which has
not been the case recently when it comes
to other
areas germany says it supports poland's
actions at the border but we've also
seen poland using force to push back
migrants
it is a problem it is a serious problem
in two issues
one is
we have to
control borders and we have to control
the situation
of migrants refugees and migrants coming
to the eu
obviously mr lukashenko decided to use a
i would say hostile instrument and using
human beings uh as such a hostile
instrument which is
which i really condemn which is
a tragedy a human tragedy
on the other side
um europe as a whole not only poland but
europe as a whole we have to uh
get our homework done we know that we
have been knowing this for years now to
have a a common european union uh
agreed policy on on migration and and
asylum um and we don't have that right
now and that is catching up with us now
on the situation
and we've got news tonight that eu
foreign ministers um have agreed to slap
new sanctions
on belarus
in your opinion is that going to be
enough to get
lukashenko to
stop what the eu calls state-sponsored
human trafficking
i would say it's worse than
state-sponsored human trafficking it's
it's uh it's hostile it's hostile
towards poland it's hostile towards the
european union generally
uh because obviously mr lukashenko is uh
is trying
to get some sort of revenge some sort of
bargaining position towards the european
union is using human beings for that so
um
it's it's an awful situation
i hope that the russian federation is
not um
using the opportunity to be a a part of
a solution of the problem and not one of
the causes of the problem but yes we
have to put sanction on it i i support
this uh
i support this what the european leaders
of the european union decided today
and i hope that uh we hear
where different different reactions from
from mints so far on this on this
on these sanctions i hope that they will
have a
an impact on mr lukashenko
it's hard to imagine though mr aqvedi
that the the president of belarus
would have signed off on
on bringing these migrants into the
country
without the support of russian president
vladimir putin and yet we've got germany
calling on putin now to put pressure on
minsk um
how can we how can we realistically
expect him to do that isn't he part of
the problem in the eyes of europe
well that's the question i just ask is
he part of the problem is he part of
solution in my experience so far uh
the role of of vladimir putin was to
cause a problem and then
offering them himself as a solution
also at the same time
um this is too serious to play these
games um this is very very serious for
the integrity of the european union but
also for
all those human individuals that are
affected so so violently it's uh it's
it's a shame um
we have
we have to be very clear on this one
that we expect not only mr lukashenko
but also mr putin to be part of the
solution
lawmaker matthew hafferty joining us
tonight mr harvey it's good to see you
again we appreciate your time
and your insights thank you
thank you
you